so Bruce thank you so much for joining
us today we're really excited to talk
about your part in the Palo Alto stories
campaign for killing animals it's all
right okay great and first off let's
start with them how did you first meet
James Franco oh cool um I met James my
first year and while you it was it was
his first year to be bourbon cafe
together at the NYU film program um I
met at an orientation you know we were
just sitting together and we like
actually nine together to take our three
pictures sort of tapas things small talk
stuff like that Logan became became
close friends through through that year
the year after at Film School where he
just had worked on each other's film
projects you know like um he shot one of
his movies on my apartment and maybe
crew together a bunch of a bunch of our
friend mutual friends films he shot one
of my films every were like just like
collaborating it on on these student
film projects and um and it was great
because when as when Jane started
working on like his art films and some
independent projects he was very very
loyal and kind to like my students and I
brought us on board and I asked us to
like how how bout with it and I gave us
not give a lot of us I got first film
jobs outside school yeah so it's been
it's been awesome that's how we DP first
connected became homies with the idea of
Palo Alto and all the stories with it
for a feature film did this begin with
all of you talking or did he pitch you
all the ideas about the various stories
um it kind of it was it was it was kind
of organic where we were fresh mushroom
I guess before Gabrielle andina bad but
for me we were working on this other
project in detroit and he showed me a
book which it just came out so i read it
and we were just talking about it
afterwards and and then he was talking
about it and it came up don't copy
potentiate that said i was very
interested you know about to do it no
these stories here I really resonated
with me and and and and James is very
you know very like interesting driven
were you know if he get excited about
South Asian says let's do it you know it
happens kind of you know so I based on a
very quick conversation you know of a
sudden the Box talk started rolling in
his pens know yeah and also emerged from
this from yeah the video after that he
started working the spray start writing
the script and he's gonna know he's been
very helpful without getting feedback
stuff like that and yeah it's better
none of them socially kind of camo
medicate her conversation how long have
you been working on just one Bruce I've
been working the script for about a year
now it's been a since the beginning of
okay yeah a bit over a year and a half
since that's trying to write january two
thousand twelve when i first started
working on it and it gon put all changes
you notice it's been is tricky because
I'm adapting for different short stories
with four different you know narrative
are two different characters and I try
to find an interesting way to make bad
as everything was like a
was a was my initial creative challenge
you know but I know yeah so but that was
a strong initial yeah that's why I has
been taking it a bit of time